every once in a while I'll eat canned
food and butts easily like in a dark
time of my life
round bread razinin
flavored you know oh it's coming I
loosened it for you yeah sure I like it
[Music]
it's so rate to me it doesn't taste like
raisins though I do feel though if they
would serve this to me on a plate at a
fancy restaurant I'd be like Walsh on
things I'll make it y'all
you can't can Bret pop I for one would
rather die by zombies a sample of
rattlesnake meat in the purest form god
it's awful looking how red to rattle
think this was a very quick escalation
that smells pretty damn good it's not
small no that's almost snake Cheers I
[Music]
mean it's more like the venison pork
fine it's a spine there's a snake spine
in here we work hard we deserve boneless
canned food and especially boneless
rattlesnake like you could definitely
like put this in like foods that the
chicken would be in or something and you
cuz you just pass off and get away with
it I hope there's a prize in here and
it's just a little rattle it's octopus
its octopus oh don't waste time nor
money in cooking it cutting it or keep
it frozen oh it's a temperature yeah
tentacle when they get calamari all the
way through like oh I want the Rings I
don't want this stuff wouldn't can I
call you would hang out of people that
say stuff like that breath really fishy
it's too chewy it's like it never ends
like I keep chewing I know to go away I
think the flavor keeps coming now
oh I thought I mean if you're trying to
improve your jaw strength yeah like yeah
yeah yeah it feels like gum
oh stop it fried chicken and a can frag
kick in so you're giving me fried
chicken in a can it's not even real
fried chicken how does it be that fit
there's no reason it seems to be this
big oh yeah sounds like it smells like a
fancy piece it became a liquid so bad
chicken they're vegetarian they won't
know I don't know effect you can taste
that cuz they're vegetarian it makes me
feel lonely are you gonna give us a fake
turkey now since give me ham as a fake
processed Turkey McCann alligator in
Cajun style gravy yeah okay to get again
that smells delightful it looked a
primordial as [ __ ] it was like a cup of
noodles like with likes watching them
really Cajun nice spice if I had to have
a choice during the apocalypse or
whatever this would be it's too soft
it's too soft this is open up like a
whole new world for me cuz this is like
not bad I don't think most people have
alligator and rattlesnake canned foods
but for a lot of people canned food is a
reality it's a part of life it's
something you need to eat to survive the
fact that I can sit here in a chair
surrounded by lights and say which ones
I you know joke about which ones tasted
disgusting to me I mean that's coming
from a place of privilege and I don't
forget for a second how lucky we are
yeah but also [ __ ] that's not I want to
eat it ever again true how does smoke
flavor and ingredient
I don't know maybe they just have smoker
standing there at the end vodka yeah and
now you are practically we smoke clear
air so they're French as well I mean if
I had to hire a person to smoke on my
food I would hire a French person
because at least would be sexy